for those who can't afford to travel
what is the best way to expand your mind
it's a great question Katie I think I
think the reality would be if you live
in it like cosmopolitan city like
Toronto New York or near a city you
could actually go there tongue tons of
amazing communities you know this
massive Cantonese community Mandarin
community Indian community in a
Bangladeshi community in all these
places so again it depends first of all
kind of stick to what is your idea what
is your product what is what is your
mission and then think about where where
is the audience is going to be the
market people it's who are going to be a
customers and and then even physically
you might find that the city near you
where there were represented or the
demographic two were represented and
then the next question is that's not the
case I don't know say you live in the
middle of the Midwest in in the u.s. in
a kind of rural community then the great
news is the power the Internet's changed
everything in the last 20 years so you
can go online you can find any cuz
you've got you know encyclopedia the
palm of your hand where you can find and
and the other thing I found some great
entrepreneurs recently they've just
built a virtual business of colleagues
they've met around the world through the
internet you know there's actually
someone who's published a book and they
self published it and they actually got
the editor I think from Turkey ah you
know they're at a new york state but
they got the guys in terms of the book
binding out of Canada so you know that
the world is a virtual world that's all
there for you and I think the
opportunity and actually this really
helps diversity in creativity is this
tons of resources and brilliant people
around the world what there's some
billion people but there's a lot of
people who want to support your success
or your idea who are intact resources
and they can they can either you know
even be mentors to you to help you on
your journey and through social media
there's a great way of connecting them
so and the nice thing about you know
social media is is that
most abundant trust it's almost like
when we meet people we have to get to
know them but with social media you kind
of meets on socially and the
automatically trust them and if they
have got something that helps your idea
come to market then why it's worth
testing that and pursuing that and you
actually can build a business and you
can educate yourself Katie I think very
clearly around whereas your audience
whereas your market and who's the
network of people I need to do to meet
that idea come to reality a build of
business and it's all available through
social and it's all available through
the internet so I would really encourage
I'm obviously a really social by coming
on this show there's probably loads of
people listening now talking paying
questions and who could be a really
powerful when your network to help your
idea come to market listen Katie I think
this is part of entrepreneurship you
never have all the resources you want to
do the thing that you want to do you got
to find another way to get started right
don't let the fact that you don't have
the money to travel be the reason why
you don't go out and try to experience
your mind right and you know I I don't
have a building so I can't you know
we're always going to have these reasons
why we can't do the things
entrepreneurship resourceful nuts and
find in a way so what can you do in your
local city to find a way maybe there's
meetup groups you know there's salsa
classes here in Toronto I don't have to
go you know to different countries to
learn how to dance salsa there's
different activities you can do around
there's different videos you can watch I
learned a ton from my own videos where
we cover you guys give us suggestions on
videos people to cover people have never
heard of who or have had massive success
in countries outside of north america
and i get to learn from that and so it's
just finding a way what what do you want
to learn what are the skills what are
those what are the people you want to be
able to connect with there's probably a
local group already covering that in
some way and if not there's definitely
one online you can get involved with so
much more just about the resourcefulness
than the lack of resources
you